okay got kid I guys it's your boy
psychobabble here yeah yeah we're gonna
play this Nick game come fall out
I don't forget about how we're gonna
[ __ ] play it cuz people keep asking
me tell you know this is gonna be long
polite there okay okay I've gotta get ya
uh-oh fallout 4 okay okay got a good I
guess that makes sense follow through
his last one who grabbed get war just
the more never changes no no
mrs. Darmody in the year nineteen
forty-five Beckett my great-great
grandfather
serving in the army
wondered when he'd get to go home to his
wife is a oh vangelis ain't never seen
at gather a kid he got his wish when the
u.s. ended world war 2 by dropping
atomic bombs on Hiroshima okay can I be
sake that's beautiful come ere yet
awaited Armageddon instead
something miraculous happened we began
to use atomic energy not as a weapon but
it's a nearly limitless source of power
who people enjoyed luxuries once thought
the realm of science fiction domestic
robots fusion powered cars portable
computers but then in the 21st century
people awoke from the American dream
years of consumption led to shortages of
every major resource
the entire world are ever whoo peace
Freddy became a distant memory
it is now the Year 2077
we stand on the brink of total war and I
am afraid
for myself for my wife
for my infant son because of my time in
the army taught me one thing
instead war war never changes out gud
gud get gud otherwise in all the games
would get boring heard Idzik a theory
that the world only has wars to create
games you know okay this is dennis
rodman warren ever changes you're gonna
knock him dead at the veterans hall
tonight hun you think absolutely now get
ready and stop hogging the mirror right
oh okay oh okay a is the face we a
strong face good good good um oh very
dark right doc I'm very interesting very
interesting oh what's his face right
here okay Oh haircut oh well since this
is a game afraid I'll like you know like
we got a we got to make this freedom so
we gotta have a churro symbol a true
symbol in the face of freedom is named
um Trump okay guys looks like we got
ourselves a down a true
gut gut gut ready to lead the nation
auto saving but let's get her real same
in there okay get hello beautiful hey
hon I'm hurrying up ok get cut very nice
place hand a door door another fine
product of general atomics international
good get a hammer I love hammers a brac
so for all your cleaning needs heck yeah
oh good i know that's a bobble this
gotta be a bobble head around here loves
a little bit toy block ok ok it's good
we're one do it hello get a god that
smell that wall one day I got get 0 spin
it like I have a little Trump by a
little Trump ok ok open up that's right
i got got this is all very good
okay yeah hold that hold that a nice
little house we really need to get those
vacation photos developed Wow place
looks so nice out there war never
changes got that right very nice okay I
thought that'd be a bobblehead around
here somewhere but that's okay it's okay
y'all need one instant mash fancy lad
snack cakes blam Co mac and cheese
expires in never can't go there there
Ken very nice the sugar bombs are
delicious and percent daily value above
beautiful house beautiful out vault-tec
good yep it's probably that salesman new
cola thanks cold activate someone's at
the door but they they got away if they
had to wait how can someone so small
drinks so my parent I yep yep very slate
car look at how is it vault-tec okay
good hey just check or crack there's a
lot of stuff going on right here I gotta
be Sarah good morning vault-tec kali hey
and an adjusted yeah out of here
whatever you're selling I'm not buying
oh no worry sir no worries at all I love
capitalism but I hate peasants not today
you can't begin to know how happy I am
to finally speak with you I've been
trying for days it's a matter of utmost
urgency I assure you and all right now
um can I hey I want to talk to you know
you do now I know you're a busy fellow
so I won't take up much of your time
time being
hmm precious commodity I'm here today to
tell you that because of your family
service to our country into the local
vault ok get vault 111 and now thanks no
thanks I go I go a Wayne yeah that's
natural in a moment we do need to verify
some information to make sure you're
cleared for entrance in the unforeseen
event of total atomic annihilation that
come back some other time come on on
it's just a little paperwork no no get
out of here get get how do you close
this thing I said that said no and are
you saying yes so there is really did
splendid let's get to it Oh name pad
trunk strength of charisma it's like
through the roof intelligence actually
what is this do ok get good
actuality and dorrance reception okay
this is going through the roof oh let's
see here ten actually jellies are in for
it and you're okay so and the rest is
charisma okay wonderful that's just
gonna walk this over to the vault
congratulations on being prepared for
the future um thanks again hey its peace
of mind that's right the little
paperwork right for you and Shawn no
price is too high of course of course
good answer I have my moments like this
okay codsworth okay okay apply that to
most important sambrial putting up a
wall he loves that okay I got
hey how's my little guy hey yeah well I
think listen after breakfast I was
thinking we could head to the park for a
bit weather should hold up yeah sounds
like fun LLL codsworth what's wrong hi
baby Hey huh what's wrong with codsworth
and has yes followed by how much
watching tape a great sounds of
explosions where r because relation one
listened to a Falls Count unconference
stations we do have coming in that's a
confront reports I repeat confront
reports of nuclear detonations in New
York and Pennsylvania oh great great my
god
oh my god we we need to get to the ball
now I could've rather Quran my car is
beautiful uh yeah crap i forgot about
the baby oh she got it good
hello Bob
residents say excuse me this is just a
god
Hey oh hello Elena excuse me okay okay
let's go let's go hey there hello sir
[ __ ]
ah that's beautiful
that's a sorry
you don't get it I'm going in you can't
charm uh excuse me guys baby uh I am
very important we need to get it we're
on the list infant adult male adult
female okay go ahead thank you good luck
ma'am youtube com please come on what's
gonna happen where's uh where's the
vault tec there
let's go let's go oh oh hello is that
anything important in here now Donna
okay I've got a crane we're building the
wall I hope that doesn't get delayed sir
we need to set you down to the ball step
on the back door
my honey is my honey back okay we're
gonna be okay oh god it's crazy you
great to be rich we love you too it is
great to me rich it's all I gotta say
hold on oh it's good to look into that
Oh
ah
I mean there's a reason we separated the
lower class from the higher class
we did it we made it everyone please
step off the elevator and proceed up the
stairs and an orderly fashion ain't no
need to worry folks Swenson waited in
our new home we were I think here excuse
me I didn't saw yes up the stairs i'll
stop the stand up the stairs we left a
minute later no no we don't don't recall
talking about that you're safe now very
nice very nice i approve step over to
the table take a suit and I mail just
this way female welcome
you'll need your seats before thank you
further Thanks okay good just follow the
doctor here he'll show you where to go
all right follow me see this is our home
okay oh you're gonna love this is one of
our most advanced facilities not that
the others aren't great minds your home
everything what if they didn't make it
how long do you think we'll be down here
Oh we'll be going over home at an
orientation justice I've got orientation
Ella sir how's checking everyone off the
list take a minute we're comfortable
prepared for the future right
just step in here and put your vaults
you know I've good okay is this the one
I step in ladies right here see ya over
here over here honey such a lovely
family you have I hope you'll see this
as your new home oh wait hey baby I'm
here I'm comforting my little guy I'm
not going far I'll just be over there
there you see daddy's not going far all
set just step inside and put on your
bones hey eat is he talking to me or
oh very nice very elitist gott gud
guitar decontaminate and depressurize
before we head deeper just time for a
whole new life my baybay of course
complete hey Ted getting cold in here
hey hey I demand an answer
they might stop I'm gonna like this
whole time ok it's called I've got to
get again okay it's all gone now oh
let's just it done
that bears I like that
Oh what is God on ES uh ma'am ah ok
that was kind of a stop but uh chase ass
and out yes
i canna cover the ana